last question today hey David what's
your most vivid experience of culture
shock you know growing up when I would
go back as many of you know I was born
in Argentina and moved to the United
States when I was five years old and
would go back to visit sometimes every
year but sometimes every three or four
years depending on what was going on in
life at the time when I would get back
to Argentina I would experience some
culture shock at the time being a kid I
wasn't really traveling a lot where I
was being exposed to new cultures on a
regular basis so I wasn't really
accustomed to familiarizing myself with
different cultures on a regular basis so
when I would go back to our gen Tina I
would just have like a general culture
shock it wasn't about anything in
particular it wasn't about the time
people eat dinner or the way people
relate to each other or anything in
particular it was like an overall
culture shock
more is an adult I really haven't
experienced you know the the major
culture shock I've experienced is more
within the United States than outside of
it and this actually goes to something
I've been thinking out for thinking
about for a while and I've talked to
friends about recently which is that I
believe that within the United States
there are more significant cultural
differences than there are between
metropolitan coastal city dwellers in
the United States and city dwellers in
Western Europe for example in other
words I find that although there are
obviously cultural differences between
Bostonians and Parisians that Bostonians
and Parisians have a lot of things in
common that a Bostonian and someone from
Appalachia or Appalachia I don't know
how its won at this point or South
Dakota or rural Wyoming would have I
find that when I go like when I travel
to northern Humboldt County California
that I had nothing in common with the
people there we were all lived in the
United States we all spoke English but I
had far less in common with them than I
do with people in Montreal or people in
Madrid and and that is part of the
United States really having very
disparate cultures within it I feel like
the language piece is a big aspect so if
you grow up in the United States are
used to only speaking English yeah and
you know you say say you go to
for a month and you have a very tough
time communicating with people you're
gonna get some culture shock from that
yeah but I feel like you get used to
that yeah after a while you get used to
the fact that people speak a different
language doesn't mean you understand it
you might start picking up a few words
but I do think that as far as the shock
element you were just - that I after
spending several days in in northern
Humboldt County or after spending time
in rural northern Indiana as I got to do
about six or eight months ago
the culture differences don't evaporate
after a week whereas I get used to
hearing Dutch or French or whatever
after a few days in a European city I
wouldn't say that I've experienced
culture shock myself but in talking to
people it sounds like people tend to get
it coming back to their home country oh
that's rather than visiting and I think
that's what you expressed that's that's
pretty interesting
yeah yeah I'm open to hearing from
people and I've never traveled to Asia
and I know that there are folks who have
traveled to Asia who described culture
shock is much more significant and I'm
hoping to visit Asia in the next few
years but I'd be sort of open to that
being a different experience send me
your thoughts you've got a great bonus
show for you today
two ways to access it WWN pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
give you access to the supporter only
world-famous bonus show